so Charles are delighted to have you
here at collector mania today of course
everyone's excited as always about Game
of Thrones have you found shooting
season 3 compared to previous seasons
but we shot it last year so it needs a
while ago now I'm kind of gearing myself
up the season 4 but the whole thing is
one it's really well written and and
then it's organized like a military
operation it's incredibly well organized
and it's a joy to do it's great it's
terrific viewers since we last spoke to
you about Game of Thrones and they were
kind of wondering whether Tywin is
actually evil or is he just doing what
he has to do on Game of Thrones what's
your take on that Tywin is just doing
what he has to do it's a feudal society
that he lives in and he has to retain
his position and he can only do that
from being strong and ruthless I'm
afraid the great sparring partner great
verbal sparring part of this season in
Dinah Riggs character Leno what's it
been like welcoming her to the cast and
do you think she's a match for Tywin
she's trying to be know I've known
Dianna for a long time and she's the
kind of female version of Tywin
Lannister but she's she ain't gonna get
the better of me she's trying there
isn't she she now time and of course is
very clever but it was interesting to
see him being outfoxed by a child in a
way because ayah was right and his nose
all the time wasn't he now what do you
make of us
she's the character he's very very
clever she's kind of streetwise is that
girl
and maisy who plays her is dis a
complete joy to work with but yeah I
mean there were times when you know she
was coming she was wrong footing tyranny
but I think she commanded his respect
because of that he works out who she was
maybe if he hadn't have been occupied by
other things like thinking someone was
out to try and kill him yeah given a bit
more time and circumstance he would have
probably worked out what if he would
have put people on the ground to find
out there's an interesting conversation
you had with Cersei telling her that you
didn't mistrust occur she's a woman but
more like because she was as clever as
she thinks she is now that got me
thinking if she's not as clever as she
thinks she is its Tyrion as clever as he
thinks he is and it's Tywin as clever as
he thinks he is Tywin is as clever as he
thing to you yes and so is Tyrion and
the problem with Tywin and Tyrion one is
that he's not perfect you know and if
he'd had his way he would have just let
him float out to sea when he was born
but also you know he knows that that
Tyrion is what he lacks in physical
stature he more than makes up for in
intellect
and Taiwanese well aware of that who do
you think's better at the game of
Thrones do you think Tywin or Tyrion is
better
Tywin because he's in a he's in a more
privileged position if Tyrion had more
going for him he would be just as good
as tyrant someone who isn't as good as
either it's definitely Joffrey I think
that you Joffrey
we've seen some very interesting scenes
of you this season one of them we saw
with Cersei and you were she was saying
oh you try and control him and you I
will thank you very much so do you think
that Tywin and Margaery Tyrell who seems
to finding a good job of controlling
Joffrey so far are the only people
capable of controlling even Game of
Thrones at the moment that's how it
would appear yes yeah do you think
there's anybody who might be coming up
who might be a match for him he seems to
be worried about Daenerys wasn't he was
asking you about Danny and her dragons
yeah
I think if and when those two meet if
he's still alive he'd better be very
very careful because she's a very
powerful woman yeah what's it like
working with Peter Dinklage he's so
fantastic as Tyrion and also Jack
Gleeson he does a superb job making
Joffrey such a nasty piece of work yeah
I mean jack is actually a very very
sweet boy and very bright very
intelligent young man with a lot of
natural talent he's terrific Peter is
one of the nicest people I've ever met
he's a supremely gifted actor and very
very smart and he's a joy to spend time
with I'm very very fond of Peters great
guy I've heard that you are apologizing
Tim sometimes for the kind of things you
have to do on set yeah I spend a lot of
time apologizing to Peter because I
treat him like [ __ ] talking about [ __ ]
it was a great thing were timing comes
in to the throne room towards the end of
season two and he's on a horse who else
could do that but him and of course he's
a horse shits on the floor the very
before you come saying could anyone else
get away with it no that was that was
great I mean it's wonderful isn't it you
know that was a terrific scene to shoot
because you know I'm an actor we love
showing off and to actually ride into a
room full of people on the back of a
horse is quite something
the horse is fonder they were very well
behaved as well
we have great horses working on this and
they where they come from an
organization called The Devil's Horseman
who provide horses for the film industry
and they're very well schooled well
behaved horses and they know the
business you know they hear action and
they know that that's when they start
work and they get used to hitting a mark
and then after a while they get bored
you know then you really have to keep
them in line but they're they're
terrific animals to work with would you
like to say you two fans of Game of
Thrones who are watching this interview
thank you for watching Game of Thrones
as much if you have please continue to
watch Game of Thrones because it gets
better and better and better and better
and
we're now in May and we start shooting
season four at the beginning of July and
it'll probably appear April of next year
so be prepared for that because it's
going to be really really good
you